yadi and molina is behind the plate for
st louis
adam right on the mound
start number 301 together
and like we said during the open
more than likely you'll never see it
again you know what you got a lot of the
sinker throws the cutter really
effective especially to the lefties and
old uncle charlie has been his bread and
butter for years that thing is still
good
trey turner at the top of the dodger
lineup riding a 14-game hitting streak
outfield is straight away in the 2-2
pitch swung on and missed another
breaking ball slowly to the plate
couldn't hold up first strikeout
for all uncle charlie one away in this
first inning here's max muncie
curveball ripped through the right side
bishop pass the diving edmond and the
dodgers have their first base runner on
a one out single from max muncie one on
one out from mookie bets who like muncie
was out of the starting lineup came in
late
he starts one the other way there's an
opposite field approach for a base hit
they've got back-to-back knocks here in
the first
that was a really nice approach there's
corey seeger this ball's hit well to
left field by seeger it's going back it
kicks off the base of the wall center
fielder harrison bader has to come over
and play in muncie around third he'll
score here comes bets and bets is tagged
out head first slide molina leaning back
he's able to get the hand of mookie
rookie is thrown out but the dodgers do
get a run on a double by corey seeger
this ball carrum's right off the bottom
right to harrison bader who throws a
strike to sosa and the one-two pitch to
smith
back to bueno he's got it
on the mound for the dodgers is mitch
white last start and the majors came on
august 29th against the rockies remember
he gave up that three-run home run to cj
crone in the first inning and was not
nearly as efficient as he's been lately
only lasted three and a third
last outing was in a ball
six innings only 60 pitches they made
sure he's on full rest to start tonight
headman a base head
into the gap in left center cut off by
taylor tommy the wide turn around first
base and a lead off single a good start
here for tommy edmond gets himself a
fastball was able to lay off that
breaking ball inside this thing's center
cut paul goldsmith sitting in game two
at three hits in game one leads the
cardinals
and fifth in the national league 148
hits
sinking out to left and
no catch gets under the glove of chris
taylor back-to-back singles there's
nolan arnado runners at second and third
orinato hits it sharp lady short
run will score
picked out of the dirt by pujols as
nolan orenado is driven in 91. here's
yada year molina hitting 333 with two
outs and runners in scoring position la
picked up a run in the first and the
cardinals have answered
and molina hits it out to deep left
field at the wall gone
yachty
goes deep cardinals on top molina with
home run number 10
3-1
st louis
seventh time in his career he's had a
season of ten or more home runs
on the right-hander turns and delivers
the two-two
breaking ball this one is hit down the
first base line it is picked up by gold
schmidt he wins the foot brace to the
back
and the dodgers for the second straight
inning are retired in order two and a
half innings in the books at busch
stadium it's the cardinals three dodgers
one ball in two strikes to goldschmidt
one out nobody on 3-1 cardinals bottom
of the third white fires
swinging a miss strike three got
goldschmidt strikes out edmond then
strikes out goldschmidt
3-2 pitch foul tipped into the glove of
smith and mitch white strikes out the
side two three go the cardinals on to
the fourth inning it's the cardinals
three dodgers one two down for smith
wayne wright trying to become the second
pitcher in baseball to 15 wins this year
aureus of the dodgers 16 on a hop to
sosa to his left
and throws his strike to goldie three up
and three down for the third straight
inning ten in a row set down
by adam wainwright the one-two he throws
it again and gets that big strikeout
i needed it there and got it his fifth
of the game and importantly two gone in
the fourth
up to edmundo soso with two gone here in
the fourth here's a swing and a shot up
the middle base hit a base hit to center
for sosa scoring molina 4-1 cardinal how
about this piece of hidden right here by
edmundo sosa this is a good slider it's
down and it's away from mitch white
and sosa shoots it right back up the
middle eight of the last nine balls in
play have been ground balls bellinger
the only guy that elevated against him
and it was a routine fly to center
as bellinger sends one out to deep left
center on the move it's bader he is
there adam wainwright has retired 13
dodgers in a row halfway through the
fifth inning in st louis cardinals four
dodgers one adam wainwright is allowed
three hits they came in succession in
the first inning since then he has been
marvelous 15 in a row
muncie turns on the ball sends it in the
air deep right field and there it goes
micey with his 31st home run of the
season the dodgers with their first base
runners since the first inning their
first run since the first inning a 4-2
game and the first home run hit against
adam wainwright in a long long time
almost 50 innings tyler o'neil the
runner at third base
lars newt barr is the runner at second
and edmundo sosa is at first two odds
bases loaded the pitch swung on a ground
ball to short backhanded by seeger
throws across the diamond to pujol said
first to retire bader so the cardinals
will leave him loaded they get nothing
seven or more innings 15 times this year
and he's 9-2 in those games it's silly
he makes it look easy and it's anything
but
ground ball
orinato
dodgers have seen that a time or two on
both ends but another one two three
inning hurled by
adam wainwright tommy feliz on the pitch
here in the bottom of the seventh in a
4-2 game
right strokes a deep flat ball to center
bellinger going back to the wall to make
the catch
wainwright sends it on a ride straight
away center field and bellinger with
just enough room deep enough though to
bring him to their feet in combination
with the seven great enemies on the
mount and now you start thinking it's
maybe not just the eighth but what about
the ninth if he can get through justin
turner homer twice in the ball game
yesterday
in the air right field
wainwright is through eight
second straight inning three up and
three down for wainwright he's going to
go after a complete game
banners tyler o'neal 3-2 hit a ton into
deep left did he get enough at the wall
he did
into the dodger bullpen
tyler o'neill
number 24
and some insurance late for cindy lewis
adam wainwright looking for his fourth
complete game of the year and the 28th
of his big league career the 1-0 pitch a
curve is pulled down behind basement for
seeger
turner's into score bets headed for
third a 5-3 game and the tying run
reaches and here comes mike shield he's
going to the bullpen and listen to this
ovation
one smith
pokes one to right at new bar he's got
it that's a coming to score it's a 5-4
game two outs three and two
in a one-run game
he got him the cardinals hold on
and they win it five to four gallegos
gets the final two
[Applause]